now president biden is getting to bed
extra early tonight i'm told because
after all last night's kennedy center
honors had him out way past his bedtime
oh hop knobbing with bette midler and
lauren michaels it's thoroughly
exhausting anyway so well tomorrow he's
gonna dial in to what's being dubbed a
virtual summit with vladimir putin at
the top of the discussion list is
ukraine where russian troops have
amassed at the border
these latest satellite images from
russia suggest moscow is now engaged in
an unprecedented build up near the
ukrainian frontier enough to mount an
overwhelming invasion u.s intelligence
says russia is preparing to invade
ukraine with nearly 175 000 troops tens
of thousands of russian troops have
deployed on its border with ukraine
revealed in these satellite images
well the sad fact is biden is so weak
that putin feels perfectly confident to
start issuing demands even before the
talks begin
president vladimir putin is expected to
issue president biden an ultimatum
during their video meeting tuesday
guarantee that nato will never expand
into ukraine or russia might soon launch
an offensive against its neighbor
meanwhile the ukrainian defense minister
is on cnn giving biden advice
i would like to ask him
to
very
understandable articulate to mr putin
that
no
red lines from kremlin side could be
here red lion is here in ukraine we need
modernization of weaponry we have we
need um electronic warfare and etc
the etc is what costs a lot of money now
although he claimed ukraine won't need
us or nato boots on the ground
we know how risky this situation is
especially with incompetence like
general mark milley and defense
secretary lloyd austin in charge
now they couldn't beat the taliban
we were humiliated in afghanistan
but they're going to scare off putin
and by the way
all this is unfolding as americans trust
in the military is declining
now one recent poll found that just 40
percent of americans place a great deal
of trust in the u.s military that's down
70 from 70 percent in november 2018
and dropping 11 since february
now for some reason the biden team
thinks putin will be intimidated by
state department spokesperson ned price
if russia chooses to fail to de-escalate
if russia chooses to move forward
with any plans
it may have developed to
continue its military aggression or to
aggress militarily
upon ukraine to violate ukraine's uh
sovereignty its independence its
territorial integrity uh we and our
allies would be prepared to act
now is it just me or does he seem to be
like a little boy who just rummaged
through his dad's closet is walking
around the house wearing his suit as a
gag
now notice by the way the much more
passive tone these clowns use when
they're talking about china
we're clear-eyed about the challenge
that china presents
but china's not 10 feet tall do you
think it's time to speak more boldly or
clearly when referring to china the
communist party and its communist
ambitions
well i think we're we're doing a lot of
that you know we'll continue to speak uh
very clearly about our concerns
but again
we're in a competition with china uh and
but and we don't have to be
in a conflict
but conflict is precisely what plenty in
the military industrial complex are
itching for in the russia ukraine
situation
now publicly austin kept the
conversation very general
we're going to remain engaged with our
our allies in our region and our
partners in the region
and and we're going to continue to do
everything we can to help
provide ukraine the capability to
protect the sovereign territory
now translation americans will foot the
bill again
the ukrainians know this and they're
gleefully fanning the flames do you
believe russia will invade i will not
believe that russian will
have a victory russian
guys also will come back
in the
coffin
coffins now this type of rhetoric is
really foolish
if our so-called european allies are so
worried about russia
why are they buying so much natural gas
from them
and why do nato countries invest so
little in their own militaries
the eu's economy is multiples bigger
than russia's germany's alone is more
than twice as big so why isn't germany
germany funneling troops eastward the
answer is they don't really care about
ukraine
because if russia is such a menace why
did biden approve nordstrom 2
why did biden whip our own oil and gas
industry and drive up the cost of fuel
and make putin even richer
if he were really worried about russia
he'd want to keep our energy prices low
here at home
the truth is biden gave putin a huge
amount of leverage and he's about to use
it to embarrass biden on the world stage
which we told you would happen
declaring war on america's energy
independence will only make us weaker
across the board
so right now republicans on the hill
should be laying down a marker on this
russia ukraine issue
the gop position should be that we will
not support any significant military
action against russia unless number one
congress specifically votes to approve
it and number two we have the new
leadership at the defense department and
the joint chiefs that we need
getting into some big dispute with
russia over ukraine would be incredibly
moronic now i'm sure the pentagon the
intelligence community a lot of other
so-called allies would love to see the
u.s tied down in eastern europe because
such an outcome would also be great for
china and its supporters in the american
media
but we have to resist any effort to stir
up tensions between russia and the
united states now
our military our economic and our
national security focus has to be on the
danger presented by the ccp
we just can't afford to waste time and
resources and a hopeless controversy
over ukraine
if anything we should be looking for
ways to peel russia away from the ccp
but instead
russia and china seem to be getting
closer under biden while he's bringing
the world together after all it's a
nightmare scenario for the u.s
in october it was joint naval drills
between our biggest adversaries
the biden people are clueless but the
american people are not
that same survey i mentioned earlier
noted that 52 percent of americans see
china as the top threat
up from just under 40 percent in
february this year
just 14 percent of respondents said
russia was our biggest threat
now finally even if we did have good
reasons for a conflict with russia which
we do not biden and his team are totally
in over their heads
and would certainly fail at any military
action just as they failed in
afghanistan
national security adviser jake sullivan
general milley and general austin should
have all been booted the day after we
lost 13 brave troops guarding the kabul
airport
of course no one was held accountable
and they seemed to have no regrets
except that of course lives were lost
that refusal to take responsibility for
failed strategy alone is a disqualifier
from future public service oh and let's
not forget another terrifying prospect
america at war or on the brink of war
and then something happens to biden
making kamala harris our
commander-in-chief imagine that for a
moment
the woman can't even keep staff let
alone keep track of military movements
in eastern europe
having someone as unqualified and
untalented and apparently as unliked as
this vice president
is itself an ongoing national security
threat to america
the biden people didn't take any of
these jobs seriously it was one big
exercise in diversity equity and
inclusion not merit
and now america is paying the price
so the bottom line is
biden's gang who cannot shoot straight
must not be allowed to squander any
american lives or resources on a
desperate and unnecessary conflict with
russia
and any republican that's stupid enough
to support such an imprudent effort will
end up exiled from the party and just
asked liz cheney how it feels
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else